(audience applause)
- Today's live challenge
is about cliff-hangers.
(audience cheering)
- Which...
If I hit you with this,
at least we'd know who it was.
(audience laughing)
- Soak it up.
Just think about all the
things you're going to
have to follow next season.
(laughing)
- Didn't wanna hear that.
- It's only getting
worse from here.
We're cutting to black in
the middle of the
episode next time.
(audience laughing and cheering)
- As all Walking Dead fans
know, this past season
ended with a bit of
a shocking twist.
One that I won't give away
but it had a little something
to do with Lucille here.
(audience applause and cheering)
Naturally, some fans handled
the pivotal cliff-hanger scene
with grace and tact.
(audience laughing)
Like this reasonable tweet,
which was not uncommon.
"It wasn't chilling,
it was annoying.
"F**k you Chris Hardwick.
F**k you "and your
giant Adam's apple."
(audience laughing)
(audience cheering)
- She seemed so nice otherwise.
- Otherwise.
"My giant Adam's apple?
"Don't bring little
Carl into this!"
That's what I call
my Adam's apple.
Carl (growls)
Or this tweet -
"Been busy with
Wrestlemania but f**k AMC,
"Scott Gimple for directing the
- he didn't direct it -
"directing the cliff-hanger
for season finale
"and Robert Kirkman
for allowing it."
F**k you! F**k you
Robert Kirkman,
Wrestlemania would never
pull that cliff-hanger sh*t.
(audience cheering)
Wrestlemania respects it's fans.
People were upset,
they were hoping to see
who Negan killed,
we don't know yet;
but something tells me
the cliff-hanger rage
is not going away any time soon.
So comedians, in a promo for
the next season of a show,
please give us a voiceover for
the worst cliff-hanger
you can think of -
Robert Kirkman.
- On the next exciting
episode of the Walking Dead,
we find out how mad
fans are when they learn
Negan killed Carl in the
season 6 cliff-hanger.
(audience cheering)
- World Star!
- People wanted to know!
I'm not gonna make
you wait all summer,
I'm not an a**hole.
(rock music)